[Music]
Old Navy recently stirred up a lot of
controversy with an ad that featured an
interracial couple show the ad there's
the ad right there and you know it's a
great ad many people applauded the ad
but believe it or not some people were
offended by the sight of an interracial
couple and they threatened to boycott
Old Navy kind of hard to believe
yeah and they staged yeah yeah now
personally I think seeing images of
interracial couples is yet another
powerful tool in our country's
never-ending fight against racism and
here to comment further is our good
friend Deon Cole let's get him in here
do
[Applause]
Thank You Conan I completely agree with
you the more people that see images like
this the sooner racism will become a
thing of the past
that's why I'm here today to do my part
Cindy deal with America
[Applause]
Rebecca Thank You Dion Jennifer you can
handle it America pay fine be on that's
that's great oh hold on ladies
[Music]
Just Breathe America breathe damn I'm
gonna be honest I'm not sure how this
furthers the the cause of equality and
and frankly it's a little bit sexist Oh
Xavier can a brother get a flag
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you